l'urgence c'est de pouvoir continuer à
vivre sur la planète dans de bonnes
conditions
l'urgence est de mettre fin au
réchauffement climatique dans sa
conséquence la plus dramatique est la
hausse du niveau de la mer qui menacent
très directement la survie de millions
et de millions d'habitants ceux qui
vivent sur les côtes et ceux qui vivent
dans des états insulaires et pourquoi
cette conférence la réussir est alors
que toutes les précédentes ont échoué
quand même il ya un constat alors qu'il
faut faire bonne question ça je nous la
posons tous justement pour pâques cei
sous une nouvelle fois parce que
copenhague c'était dramatique et quand
une grande déception
et puis parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya deux
choses je pense qu'ils peuvent permettre
de réussir c'est que d'une part plus
personne ne conteste les faits des
activités humaines et de la pollution
due aux gaz à effet de serre sur le
dérèglement climatique
dès qu'il est de moins en moins en tout
cas maintenant ils n'osent même plus
parler donc c'est plutôt une bonne chose
et deuxièmement on commence à comprendre
que le coût de l'inaction est beaucoup
plus lourd que le fait d'agir et que au
fond c'est un non sens économique de ne
pas agir et je dirais même plus que
c'est une chance d'avoir l'occasion de
refonder les bases du développement
économique à partir des économies
d'énergie à partir des énergies propres
à partir de l'efficacité énergétique des
bâtiments à partir de transferts de
technologies notamment l'énergie solaire
vers les pays les plus pauvres et qu'on
peut à la fois sortir de la crise
économique dans les pays industrialisés
grâce à la croissance verte et sortir de
la pauvreté dans les pays pauvres grâce
à l'accès aux énergies renouvelables
et vous pensez que les populations sont
prêtes à suivre parce que en période de
ralentissement économique quand même on
leur demande de faire des sacrifices
énergétique croyait que les gens sont
prêts à suivre côté je pense que même
les gens sont très en avance souvent sur
les états et les gens ils ont envie ils
ont envie de voir baisser leur facture
énergétique dont ils ont envie d'avoir
des logements bien isolé fois contre la
chaleur ou contre le froid ils ont envie
de rouler propre
les voitures électriques qui coûterait
moins cher ils ont envie de respirer et
de ne pas avoir l'air pollué pour eux
pour leurs enfants
ils ont envie d'accéder à une
alimentation saine parce que les terres
arrêteront d'être pollués ils ont envie
d'accéder à une eau potable au robinet
donc les gens ils ont envie ils
demandent que ça et demandent qu'à
avancer et sont bien souvent en avance
sur sur leurs gouvernants défendent et
cette cause de l'environnement depuis
longtemps voué à rio en 1992
vous sentez une évolution de l'opinion
publique il ya la fois des choses lente
et à des choses qui ont beaucoup bougé
c'est la prise de conscience c'est les
connaissances scientifiques
c'est la sensibilisation de l'opinion
publique et c'est l'engagement enfin des
entreprises et du milieu financier et
pour revenir à paris vous est ce que les
nations unies demeurent le meilleur
forum pour discuter et négocier tout
tous ces accords vous avez lancé un cri
d'alarmé vous allez dis que le processus
était trop lent trop lourd alors
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez que c'est
quand même plus de 20 ans oui dans ce
système voilà c'est la preuve que voilà
c'est beaucoup trop long trop parce que
ça fait 20 ans que l'on répète les mêmes
les mêmes procédures actuellement aussi
voyez des procédures à bonn je voyais
les résultats à l'instant sur le
sur les dépêches de presse on disait que
c'était très lent et c'est pour ça que
c'est très important qu'aujourd'hui
justement il ya un événement historique
qui vient de se passer c'est que les
chefs d'état 17 plus grands pays
industrialisés viennent de faire une
déclaration commune sur le climat c'est
vraiment unique c'est la première fois
qu'au niveau des chefs d'état se passe
un engagement extrêmement fort pour
réduire le les ressources l'utilisation
des ressources des énergies fossiles et
pour engager des actions fortes sur les
énergies renouvelables
et ça c'est bien ça veut dire qu'on ne
laisse pas à des négociateurs
institutionnels le fait de continuer à
négocier sans mandat mais les chefs
d'état prennent leurs responsabilités et
donne des instructions pour que au mois
de décembre il y à un accord vous pensez
que c'est important de politiser
exactement c'est important de politiser
au sens noble du terme c'est à dire au
delà des clivages politiques
parmi le g7 vous avez des chefs d'état
qui ne sont pas du tout de la même
sensibilité politique
et pourtant ils ont réussi à se mettre
d'accord sur des engagements extrêmement
fermes et extrêmement volontaire qu'est
ce que vous faites avec des pays comme
le canada qui sont réticents quand même
dans tout ce processus de tia rio le
canada est un pays précurseur la grille
et depuis se traîne les pieds
est ce que ça vous déçoit je préfère
voir déjà les avancées puisque entre
décembre de l'année dernière et
maintenant il ya quand même une avancée
il faut encourager à continuer à
accélérer lorsque le canada est un très
grand pays qui est regardée à l'échelle
de la planète qui a quelque chose à dire
sur le seul engagement climatique qui
subit d'ailleurs très violemment le
réchauffement climatique qui voit très
directement le la fonte des glaces dont
qui est déséquilibré aussi par le
réchauffement climatique donc c'est très
important que que le canada continue les
efforts qu'il a commencé à faire
ouais mais par exemple il ya livré ccib
réduction de 30% de ses émissions de gaz
à effet de serre d'ici 2030 c'est moins
ambitieux que celle de l'europe oui là
dessus ça vous déçoit pas est ce que
vous pensez qu'il pourrait en faire plus
mais nous ne sommes pas encore au mois
de décembre donc il ya encore une marge
de progression d'un gouvernement qui
vient d'être élu en alberta donc
souligner dabitch minutes c'est un
gouvernement néo démocrate dirigé par
une femme
les néo-démocrates chez nous c'est un
peu de la même famille politique que la
vo donc penser que ça ça peut aider
oui je pense que ça peut aider
d'ailleurs je crois que les premières
déclarations qui ont été faites vont
dans ce dans ce sens il faut du courage
et je crois que oui que je crois que le
courage sera au rendez vous je voyais un
sondage en fin de semaine où vous étiez
jugé très ambitieuse arrogante et je me
disais que c'est des qualités qu'on
recherche parfois chez un homme
politique en tout cas chez certains
hommes politiques mais je me disais
aussi que dans ce bras de fer quand même
diplomatique qui s'amorce nat d'ici à
décembre
si ce sommet est ce que ça prend pas ce
genre de qualité pour arriver à faire
bouger les gouvernements oui j'ai vu
courageuse aussi dans les amener un peu
plus bas au pays et quand même j'ai un
peu dire ce que non parce que d'abord
bon c'est la pratique de ce journal et
puis ensuite parce que vous savez quand
quand un homme est ambitieux on dit
c'est formidable il est ambitieux pour
son pays
il a de la volonté au lieu de dire
arrogant on dit qu'il est volontaire et
déterminée quand c'est une femme ça se
transforme en une femme n'a pas le droit
d'être ambitieuse une femme quand elle
est volontaire elle devient arrogante
donc ça fait des années et des années
que j'entends les mêmes sornettes
et donc je ne m'y arrête pas je fais mon
travail le mieux possible
j'obtiens des résultats mais c'est comme
ça qu'il faut continuer en terminant
quand même je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué ou si vous prêtez attention
quand vous êtes en france mais la
majorité des provinces canadiennes
étaient dirigées par des femmes en fait
donc en alberta une nouvelle première
ministre en ontario en
colombie-britannique
au québec aussi jusqu'à tout récemment
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire de voir ce
qui se passe ici à ce niveau là bas
c'est formidable ça veut dire que la
parité que nous nous imposons en france
sur les listes étaient beaucoup plus
difficile chaque fois qu'il y à un
scrutin uninominal ici
- ça se fait naturellement par le parent
lésions par les élections
ça veut dire aussi que les parties
arrivent à promouvoir des femmes donc ça
c'est une très bonne chose
vous qui avez été si près qu'ils avaient
eu ce rêve voilà on y est ce que est ce
qu'on peut abandonner son rêve est ce
que vous allez revenir je pense que vous
allez me répondre mais quand même il
faut que je me pose cette question là
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
revenir et de représenter pour l'un
c'est pas dans les intentions
vous êtes bien vous êtes mais voilà
certains trucs c'est un peu étroit pour
vous sent très gentil de leur
considération
voilà mais pour l'instant ce n'est pas
dans mes projets brian merci merci
beaucoup